now to ukraine where rescuers are still
trying to get people out of an apartment
building where russian rockets killed at
least 19 people saturday local emergency
officials say two dozen people are
trapped inside the wreckage but the
shelling isn't the only threat ukrainian
civilians are facing holly williams has
the story
nice to meet you hi vlad
welcome home sixteen-year-old vlad
bouriak has just made it home
after what he says was nearly three
months in captivity a child prisoner of
the russian military
this is the moment last week when he was
finally reunited with his father ole
vlad told us he was taken captive by
russian troops in april as he evacuated
from molitopol in southern ukraine with
other civilians
maybe kill you
write this
they threatened to kill you yes at the
checkpoint yes instead he told us the
russian soldiers took him to a jail in
occupied territory where he was held for
several weeks
vlad drew us a map of the facility it's
torture room that's the torture room and
claims he witnessed the russian guards
torturing other ukrainian prisoners did
you see that happening i see this i hear
this we cannot independently verify
vlad's story and he says he wasn't
tortured himself but he gave us a
detailed account of being put to work
cleaning the room he says was used for
torture
what did you see inside the torture a
lot of blood seeing one ukrainian
prisoner hanging from the ceiling by his
hands
learning from another prisoner that he'd
been tortured with electric shocks and
overhearing torture himself
it's crying
people
like
help us it's painful
ole buryak is a senior government
official and claims the russians knew
that and held his son hostage hoping for
a prisoner swap why would they kidnap a
16 year old
he told us the russian troops are
stealing washing machines and toilets as
well as children it's all for greed he
said
you feel good ole told us he negotiated
directly with the russian side for
vlad's release
but doesn't want to share the details
because he hopes that what happened to
his teenage son will be prosecuted as a
war crime
for cbs morning's holly williams
zaparisia ukraine